and that night I went to a party and I
there was other stuff there and it was
only three months before I ended up in
the hospital with an OG Demi Lovato is
opening up about her 2018 relapse and
overdose I got sober I teenager I wasn't
even legally allowed to drink the 27
year old stopped by The Ellen DeGeneres
Show on Thursday and got candid about
her former management team who she says
were so controlling it ultimately led
her to question her six years of
sobriety my life I just felt it was so
and I hate to use this word but I felt
like it was controlled by so many people
around me Ellen who has had Demi on the
show ten times in the past said she
learned that Demi's team used to hide
all of the sugar in her dressing room
before Demi arrived I didn't know that
until today too but I lived a life for
the past six years that I felt like
wasn't my own because I struggled really
hard with an eating disorder yes and
that was my primary problem and then it
turned into other things
Demi said her team would take the phone
out of her hotel room so that she
couldn't order room service adding that
they'd also remove any fruit from her
room because of added sugar she also
claimed that they even monitored her
Starbucks orders and Demi says that the
controlling nature of her team led her
to feeling quote really really unhappy
my bulimia got really bad and I asked
for help and I didn't receive the help
that I I needed and so I was stuck in
this like unhappy position and Here I am
sober and I'm thinking to myself I'm six
years sober but I'm miserable I'm even
more miserable than I was when I was
drinking why am I so burn Demi expressed
all of this to her team and said that
they reacted by leaving her Demi
admitted that all these complications
triggered her issues with abandonment
surrounding her birth father a former
addict himself so when they left they
totally played on that fear and I felt
completely abandoned so I drank but Demi
makes it clear that she takes
responsibility for what went down and
how far she has come ultimately like I
made the decisions that got me into
where I am today you know it was my
actions that put me in the position that
I'm in and I think it's important that I
sit here on this stage and tell you at
home or you and the audience are you
right here that if you do go through
this you yourself can get through it you
can get to the other side and it may be
bumpy but you are a 10 out of 10 like
don't forget it and as long as you take
the responsibility you can move past it
and learn to love yourself the way that
you deserve to be left and just in case
all of that didn't have you all up in
your field goods demi is releasing her
new single I loved me on Friday
this song is fun and light-hearted and
it's got like a positive upbeat message
there are songs on the album that are
ugly honest and heavy and will make you
cry and will take you there but I'm so
excited
following her appearance on the talk
show Demi shared her feelings on
Instagram writing I was so emotional I
cried when I walked offstage Thank You
Ellen for providing me a platform to
speak my truth then she shared a sneak
peak at the new jam and it is good
20:20 is already off to a great start
for Demi in February she announced she's
getting her own talk show on the new
mobile entertainment platform kwibi and
that same month she sang the national
anthem at the Super Bowl and freaking
slayed
this is your year Demi I can feel it in
my bones of course you can count on et
to bring you all the latest on Demi and
her new music so keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
and I'll see you soon